foreign
there's two amendments there will be two
amendments
thank you
good morning everybody I want to welcome
you to environment and agriculture
um I especially want to
um
welcome our substitutes I have in for
representative Morse we have
representative Horrigan this morning
good morning
for representative Brouillard we have
representative colcom good morning
for representative Creighton we have
representative bogert good morning and
Welcome to our committee I'd like to
start off this morning with the Pledge
of Allegiance and have please
representative Davis lead us
thank you
we will uh on our schedule this morning
we have our an executive session for SB
61.
and um
I'm going to open up that exact session
and I believe I have a motion from
representative Bixby
yes I'd like to
um move Amendment uh 19 uh 2023-1979h
and
uh this what this oh oh right
oh and I would second that okay so um
let's speak to your Amendment
representative Bixby yes please I'm
sorry
um so uh in this amendment I've tried to
include as much of the uh commentary and
discussion that we got on that we had uh
when we did our work session
um
a couple weeks ago uh and uh there are
with the Proviso that I also was in
contact with
um I'm not uh representatives from
stakeholders uh on uh on several sides
of the issue uh including
representatives from uh the
um North Country
um Alliance for balance change and uh
representative from the solid waste
industry and uh and represent and uh
through third parties uh representatives
from Des and uh and uh with Senator
Waters
um and uh I was getting advice about uh
what may or may not be acceptable to the
other body and
unfortunately there were several issues
that I really wanted to address in this
that would not be acceptable to the
other body and those were not those are
not included in the amendment uh that
one of those would be on the
variability of the time of travel over
the site and uh the idea that uh the
only down gradient
um
groundwater would be recognized the
ground down water gradient issue is not
as
significant because that's part of the
findings rather than part of the
legislation itself I was also not able
to get the idea that uh
the consultant should look at the state
laws in in other states
um
and I regret that I wasn't able to get
those but uh what I did manage to get
was I'll start with um
at the bottom of page one uh there was
this is at the end of the uh section
that discusses uh measures that could be
used to
um to improve to change the time of
travel measurement uh uh or or the the
ultimate distance away from a water body
um the there was discussion committee
that uh section B was uh
not what was very difficult to interpret
just for uh language reasons and I
worked on rewriting that uh and uh so
that now reads like the permit
application includes any measure
pursuant to RSA 149
m915a and the department relies on such
a measure uh in the Department's
formulation of the site's specific
setback
required by RSA
149 M7 3A the department shall include
such a measure as a condition to the
permit and I think this actually makes
that uh that requirement that any
measure that gets uh
uh used to change the uh the ultimate
setback needs to be specifically
included as a condition for the permit
and uh so that
um
that was one change uh
the uh next change is uh
the
um uh conflicts of influence conflict of
interest language uh it was pointed out
that to me that the way that we had it
set up previously was in some sense
circular and uh would actually end up
only applying to a solid waste company
whereas what we actually wanted to uh
the place where we want to prevent the
conflict of interest is with the
consultant so uh we uh and it was also
pointed out that there exists in statute
already a conflict conflict of interest
language uh and I don't remember the
citation right now but
um
I can find it if anyone later if
anyone's interested the department shall
include in a request for proposals
Provisions designed to prevent a
situation circumstance or financial
interest which has the reasonable
potential to cause a prospective
contractor's interest to interfere with
the contractor's duties under the
request for proposals and require
disclosure in the response
to the request for proposal submission
by the Consulting form firm okay there's
a typo here that we will need to
um get fixed but the consulting firm or
individual uh so uh I think that
actually does a pretty good job of
laying out what potential conflicts of
interests are and um and that uh they
need to be
um
that that uh that's something that the
department has to be careful of uh and
uh also added to uh in line 33 below
that uh when the uh consultant
um sends in their response their um
proposal for uh to the for the RFP that
proposal needs to disclose any potential
infant uh potential conflicts of
interest
um
so
uh so that conflict of interest language
was something that the committee felt uh
needed to be solidly and in place and I
think that this language does that
um the next uh another issue that we had
was that we wanted to have the report
sent directly to us and that language is
at line 35 to 37. the department shall
provide the Senate energy and natural
resources Committee in the house
environment and agriculture committee
with electronic copies of the report and
shall we make and and as it said before
it should also be on the website
um
and uh the next
uh section that uh where there's a
change is
um
the creation of an extension and this
has been
um rather complicated to negotiate uh
and
um it ended up
um
the way that we had that I had it in the
previous draft uh did not uh pass muster
with OLS because they said that there
was a
um separation of powers issue with the
way it was written and then it could
potentially create a precedent that
would be problematic
uh so uh uh it's gone through a couple
of rewrites since then including one
um that happened between nine and ten
this morning uh and uh so the the way
that reads now is if the department is
this is on page three line 29. if the
department is unable to complete
adoption of the rules as required
under this section as a result of a
natural disaster civil emergency
epidemic or pandemic pandemic or other
extraordinary circumstance substantially
interfering with the customary operation
of the department or state government
the commissioner May file for a waiver
to extend the deadline under RSA 541 A40
Roman 4. during such time the abeyance
of approval of applications as outlined
in subparagraph B of this
section shall continue in effect for no
more than 90 days
and we also increased the amount of
money available to the department to
hire the consultant from 150 000 to 200
000. so those are the changes and uh
in terms of what what I think is really
important here I think that is very
important that we have an advance for uh
uh in place either until the rules are
made essentially until the rules are
made and uh I am hoping that the
department will be able to do that
within the scheduled amount of time and
I'm confident that they have that
ability uh and I think that that Advance
is really critical uh because I don't
think that
um we should have any permits going
forward under the current rules and if
we don't get this amendment in place and
we don't get the
um
get this bill passed then the current
rules will take effect as soon as this
bill fails uh that is for me that's the
bottom line
and I
will be happy to see the discussion to
others
any discussion
seeing none of Representative germanna
thank you madam chair and I want to
thank representative Bixby for all the
hard work that he's done in
representative Murray and others
um
I'll have more to say when we get to to
vote on the the whole bill later on I'll
just add at this point that for me the
inability to add language about
variability across the site
ultimately is the straw that's going to
break the camel's back in terms of my
ability to vote for this bill or not so
I want to appreciate express my
appreciation
but also my Supreme disappointment that
that wasn't
um we weren't able to get that added to
the bill
thank you
any other discussion about this
amendment representative Howard
thank you madam chair and thank you to
the members of the committee on both
sides of the aisle who work to make this
amendment the best it could be under
these under the circumstances I intend
to vote for the amendment because it
moves us closer to being able to protect
the citizens of New Hampshire from
present and future toxins leaching from
landfills it has not gone far enough
though and I believe it this is due to
the process by which it was formed early
on the parameters were defined by A
Veiled Threat from the executive branch
then during negotiations
a representative from of the industry
most affected by this bill sat in to
basically confirm that the threat was
real I'm new at this political stuff
and
and maybe that's a good thing because
I still believe that we must put people
before Prophets to me stringent
regulation of industries that can show
the pollutants that threaten our
communities is the purview solely of
this committee and we should be able to
do our jobs unhindered by influences
with different objectives
thank you representative Howard
uh as for me I will be supporting this
amendment and I will be supporting this
bill
number one if this is something we have
been discussing for the past six years
and I'd like to see something done about
this uh citing landfills I think with
Des not uh with with des's rules
expiring next year
I believe that with this bill
they will at least have another set of
eyes helping them develop new rules
and I think that that would be a good
thing and a good step forward
so
um if anything
I think that this is that's a favorable
part of this of this bill that's before
us
representative Haskins thank you madam
chair
with respect I appreciate the work that
went into this amendment I think there
are some pieces of it that
needed to be part of it that I lament
did not become part of the amendment to
the bill
respectfully I have to vote no to this
amendment because I think those features
were critical to protect the people of
New Hampshire thus my vote
any other discussion representative
verbal thank you madam chair I I'm also
going to vote no on this amendment I I
don't believe that the Department of
Environmental Services actually needs
the help of some third-party consultant
to be able to promulgate rules relative
to landfill citing in New Hampshire we
have uh highly trained professionals
with very good pedigrees and I'm quite
certain that they can do their their job
without knowing who this third party
consultancy is to be it's impossible to
know which way they would lean whether
it be towards industry that would anger
some or whether it would be towards
strict environmental control which would
which would anger others and uh so for
for that reason I can't support the
amendment thank you madam chair thank
you any other discussion
seeing none
I would uh direct the clerk to please
call the roll for this amendment thank
you madam chair we're voting on the
adoption of amendment 2023-1979h
Madam chair
yes represent bogert
yes Representative no Representative
verville no representative Arnold
representative colcum
yes represent coulon
represent Kenny
representative Potenza
no
representative smart
represent Bixby yes representative
represent dutse
represent Murray
representing jamana yes
represent Haskins no representative
Howard
where's the NAB yes
representative Horrigan yes
Representative no
the motion the amendment is adopted
11 to 9.
thank you
I believe there's another amendment
before us
I don't
representative Potenza would you like to
make a motion
yeah so I don't know what the exact uh
procedure is that I adopt yes I'd like
to adopt the amendment which would be
1980 h
do I hear a second
representative Potenza would you like to
speak to your motion
yes
so I have a short opening statement
before I explain the substance in the
minor but critical changes that
my Amendment with my co-sponsor makes to
SB 61.
I was saddened to find out that members
of this committee run Amendment changes
by Des and Casella for approval
furthermore I was even more upset to
realize to the extent to which this has
occurred with SB 61.
Mr Demers and his client Casella have
become the gatekeeper for this
legislation
they have been allowed to dictate and
direct SB 61 by approving or not
approving languages in this bill call me
new call me naive call me whatever you
want but I will not sit silently because
it is all wrong
when we listen to paid lobbyist actors
like Casella over the real New Hampshire
stakeholders you know the citizens that
we represent
you have to speak up and you have to put
up
hence why I have introduced the Potenza
Haskins Amendment
the legislature overwhelmingly voted for
HP 56.
and with some minor changes that bill
should have been passed and signed by
the governor
but because Casella didn't like that
bill here we are representative Potenza
I don't believe we have any kind of
proof or or um
any information
regarding what Casella has said or not
said and I don't believe this bill has
really anything to do with Casella it
has or to or with Forest Lake or with
Dalton this has to do with establishing
citing rules for Des for citing
landfills and I would ex I would hope
that you would suspend any discussion
about
lobbyists or Casella or anyone else
please speak to the legislation okay the
Bixby Amendment
does nothing to improve the inherently
flawed SB 61.
it is time to call what it is there are
very bad actors that are using political
and financially lobbying efforts which
influence and create bias by the
governor and the Senate and circumvent
the obvious and blatant will of the
people our constituents that only want
clean water and not on toxic living
environments for themselves and their
families in addition many of these
constituents who have diligently and
respectfully contacted this committee
and been in attendance at committee
meetings whom have considerable and
diverse expertise on the subject will
not be ignored by me wasn't this what as
I was elected to do it is time to be
brave and make doing the right thing
popular again
so the minor changes in my Amendment
every single
um
every single amendment that
representative Bixby put in
is in
the Potenza Haskins one of 1988 and then
there's specific things that are as I go
through
grab my notes sorry
okay
sorry
so the first thing is under
in regards with necessary for rules
to
um
provide adequate protection of perennial
service water adequate has been removed
and it is provide provincial surface
water with an ample margin of safety
um
obviously adequate is uh every you know
you and I can think about what things
adequate someone else that's really more
of a determinant in an industry related
term
um ample is specifically going to help
in regards with that oh yes can you
please reference the line that you're
talking about yes
page in line
so it is
uh three
new paragraph under
is that page two page three page two I'm
sorry
three under
3A
line nine
on page two sorry
the next is a same page under B which is
um it removes the word uh representative
under B the volume gradient
so it's basically now says to measure or
model travel time and its variability
across the site
foreign
the next is on page three lines line
seven
um under under B is changed to if a
permit application proposes any measure
pursuant to 149 M9 xvea and the
department relies on those measures in
their formulation of the site-specific
setback required by 149
m73a the department shall require
implementation of those measures as
conditioned to any permit
same page under
five
um
line 16
pretty much what was added to this is
the draft request shall require each
proposal to provide a statement of any
potential conflicts of interest with any
entity that may benefit from any changes
in setback requirements indicating that
preference may be given to firms or
individuals without such conflicts of
interest or to firms or individuals with
the fewest conflicts of interest the
draft request will also indicate that
preference will be given to proposals
which demonstrate the qualified
consulting firms or individuals have
credentials and experience in evaluating
the health and safety risks associated
with the Environmental Protection as
well as the engineering and
hydrogeological aspects of landfill
design and sitting
thank you
page four
puts the legislature back in
um
in the place that it needs to be
line 10 item two the selected contractor
sells shall complete the assessment and
submit a final report to the department
whoops wait a minute that's not it sorry
oh that's missing now is it missing
is it
yes there it is okay I'm sorry
um
so it's page five line six the
commissioner of the Department of
Environmental Services show reports of
the house and
environment and agriculture committee
and the Senate energy and natural
resources committee by November 4th 14th
2024 relative to the pro progress of the
rulemaker and under this act if the
commissioner believes that he or she
will not be able to complete the
rulemaking process within the 24-month
period allotted he issues shall report
to the Committees how much time he or
she deems necessary to complete the
rulemaking process
and that is it
okay
um sorry representative Haskins thank
you madam chair
obviously
um we did not have a lot of time to put
this new Amendment together I want to
thank my colleague who happens to be on
the other side of the aisle for all her
hard work
um
I I co-sponsor this amendment because
these are the changes that many of us
wanted in the bill and
we did not get them in the amendment
we sent the Senate a very good bill they
sent us back 61 which I don't believe is
adequate protection for all the citizens
of New Hampshire
we can't be naive
there there is a reason why there's
pressure on this bill right now
and as a lake person it matters very
much to me that we are very careful
about where we put our landfills and
since there is no current need for a
landfill in New Hampshire
for probably 20 years we do not have to
bow to the pressure that we have
received so that is why I am happy to
co-sponsor the Potenza Haskins Amendment
thank you representative Haskins
representative verbal
thank you madam chair so
I'm a little nervous about the the
amendment in that it seems to be
particularly uh open-ended with respect
to the last point which originates on on
page five section four
so the the commissioner is going to
report to the legislature the progress
of the rule making and if the
commissioner believes that they will not
be able to complete the rulemaking
process within two years
that person uh the the commissioner
shall report to the Committees how much
more time deemed
necessary so if the commissioner shows
up and says boy I'm I'm close I would
say within another 10 to 12 years we're
going to have this buttoned up there's
there's no there's no pushback in the in
the amendment so in fact the the rule
making processes this amendment is laid
out potentially could be at infant item
for that reason I don't think I can
support this uh this amendment although
I appreciate the uh the intent in which
it was filed thank you madam chair thank
you
representative Bixby oh I'm sorry
representative germana you had your hand
okay thank you madam chair and thank you
representative Bixby uh I
a phrase we use a lot when we're
considering legislation is we can't let
the uh the perfect be the enemy of the
good and and that is often overused but
it is something I genuinely believe I do
feel and that's where I have been
coming again and again and again as we
think about this bill we've gotten to a
point where I I don't think we're in the
area of the good anymore so I will be
supporting the amendment
represent Bixby
yeah so
um
I wish that uh I I wish that if this
amendment were attached to the bill that
the bill would have a hope of passing
uh but uh I was told Point Blank by a
member of the other body this morning
that if the governor does not support
the bill that there would not be a
senate concurrence
and I don't like that game
I don't like the fact that we're passing
a bill that is much weaker than I think
it ought to be
but
I go back to the idea of either having
that two years of Advance or having
permits starting next as soon as the uh
non-concurrence comes down and as a
result of that I can't support this
amendment and I'll be supporting the
bill as it was previously amended
representative Howard
thank you madam chair
um
I
I've been into Bixby and and represented
representative jimana but I I am hanging
my hat on the abeyance part because I
think that if we if we were to leave any
opening
there is a very good chance that that
actors or people who don't care as much
as we do about pollution and toxins
we'll jump into the breach
representative Haskins thank you madam
chair
with respect if we don't like the way
the game is played let's not play the
game
and that's why I
co-sponsored the Potenza Haskins
amendment I don't think we should act in
good conscience under threat we are a
legislative body
we make the laws let's make a law we
believe in and if the other side doesn't
accept it that's on them thank you
representative verbal
thank you madam chair I have to admit
that I I found the testimony of
Representative Bixby to be quite
compelling uh and for that reason I've
I've changed my position I will support
this amendment but I will not be
supporting uh the the underlying Bill
thank you madam chair
any other discussion
okay representative Dotsy
thank you madam chair
um I agree I mean first of all we have
three branches of government and we have
them for a reason for checks and
balances and yes as a legislative body
we certainly have the right to put
forward any legislation that we deem is
in the best interest of the people of
New Hampshire I would have hoped that
would have been two previous bills that
came before this committee that were
vetted uh that were excellent bills they
should have passed they should have
overridden The veto but the other body
chose not to do that
however we have to recognize the
political realities we do have a
government where the executive branch
can exercise its veto power
we all agree with that even though
sometimes we don't like it so for that
reason recognizing the political Powers
I will be voting against this amendment
even though I do see what it's trying to
do and I will vote for the bill with the
appropriate Amendment hopefully because
that's the political reality that we
live under and I agree that the two the
24-month moratorium is the best deal
that we can make right now
any other comment represents suffolkitis
just want to thank everybody for their
um
their steadfastness in thinking about
this and for putting in amendments I'm
I'm very pleased because
um that's what we're here for to take
care of our stakeholders thank you
any other comment representative coulon
thank you madam chair oh yeah I'd just
like to say that um
I'll be supporting this amendment and I
just want to add a little bit of um
you know texture to it I've been put
under a lot of pressure myself and
received a lot of emails from different
people regarding this subject and I
think it is possible that some of that
um you know concern could be transferred
to the Executive Branch if we were to
pass an amendment like this
so that's my
that's what I got and uh thank you
everyone
any other comment
seeing none no I'm sorry representative
Potenza I did not see your hand
when this committee was hearing the
testimony
um
there was in a sense like a you know
from the table there was a threat like
okay well you can't make any changes to
this or you know
it's it's not going to go through the
governor is going to veto it and that is
not how things work as other
Representatives have said with their
bodies and stuff like that and
I just have to say that
putting some things in
like let's remind everybody here
that 56 was passed
you know overwhelmingly
and we're making in a sense uh a
concession a couple concessions in here
to a study that's we've made 56 a study
now and that's that's a gigantic
concession
so if we're trying to make this study a
little bit stronger
with more safeguards and guard rails
isn't that something that the governor
shouldn't object
doing the right thing we have to do the
right thing and I don't think we need to
think about what this other body or what
this other entity is doing we need to do
what's right for our constituents that's
why this is important to go through
and that's all I have to say
representative Contour thank you madam
chair I just want clarification on
something that was stated earlier
so if uh I'm just going to ask a general
question okay
so if they need more time
there is no
they can have an extension as cited
for up to 10 years
if they do not meet the deadline does
that mean that landfill citing can begin
after the two-year period with the
current rules
representative germana uh thank you and
this is a question that is in tandem
with
representative's question because I
think that is a it's a good point I if
I'm not mistaken and represented bixby's
Amendment uh which we have adopted it it
references in in terms of an extension
it references an already existing RSA
correct so I agree that the language as
it is existed in 1988 is open-ended
that's a that's really good point but I
believe that there are in fact rules
already in place regarding an extension
that I assume would be valid in this
case as well because as I said the Bixby
Amendment refers specifically to set of
rules so that's there's a question in
there is
um is there already a mechanism for such
an extension that would not in fact
leave it completely wide open
representative Murray thank you madam
Madam chair this is a question for the
chair actually
um if I may sure
um if this amendment were to be adopted
it would then supersede the previous
amendment is that not correct I am right
now checking with the clerk so I'll let
you know in a moment oh
if they are not available
15 more compatible and can be eventually
put together
any information
I will know in a moment representative
Contour thank you
um Madam chair uh and this is a question
for the sponsor of this legislation I
don't believe my question has been
answered
did you restate your question
thank you madam chair the question was
if you can extend the rulemaking process
for an infinite time period
are you still are you then able to
postpone the sighting of landfills for
an infinite time period based on the
wording in here
represent Potenza would you please reply
so I believe that this is not infinite
it is just if the they can't meet the 24
months requirement then it does go back
to effect of what the current
um statute is in place it's just of
course How It Was Written and I took
that same language from representative
Bixby
in regards with a 90-day extension
um Des can't give itself the authority
to do that so that's why this if the
department does not adopt the rules in
accordance with
um that they can basically they're
asking for it but it doesn't leave it
open-ended it goes back to the previous
year in regards what it has to be done
in 24 months
that answer your question representative
um and I just received information from
our clerk Paul Paul Smith
saying that and the question was what
happens if two amendments on a bill
passed that may not work together
in the committee and he said you have to
merge amendments to only have one
Amendment from the committee if they
don't work together it's going to be an
issue so
um seeing that
passing both of these amendments would
be problematic
and I'll just leave it at that and
representative Bixby
so I was just reading on page five uh
um starting at line six uh section Roman
four uh and I do not see in this section
anything that continues the abeyance
which means that as this amendment is
currently written the abeyance will
still disappear at 24 months and then
uh citing can begin under old rules if
the new rules are not yet written and I
think that
um
I don't think that was the intent of
this amendment I think the this that the
the intent was probably to have a
continuance of continuation of that
advance but it is not written that way
uh right now and I think that uh if the
author if the supporters of this
amendment want it to come forward in a
way that is sufficiently strong it
should probably be offered as a floor
Amendment on not offered right now as a
as as part of the committee
I would concur with that representative
Bixby
any other discussion on this amendment
representative verval
thank you madam chair and while I don't
disagree with the with the previous
discussion
um
the the odds of a floor Amendment
is certainly um
unclear especially without some
indication of a committee recommendation
so
um I don't I don't know that uh
that I would allow the concept of adding
this later as a floor Amendment as a
possibility to sway one's vote I'm not
Advocate right now I'm not advocating
for or against I just I don't I don't
think that it's necessarily a good
strategy for the sponsor and the
co-sponsor to withdraw an amendment and
hope they can get it passed on on the
floor of the house especially late in
the session where things start to get
rushed and people want to go home so I
would encourage you to to vote your
conscience on the amendment and see
where it falls thank you madam chair
thank you
we did you have a question I think
representative oh representative Haskins
I'm sorry thank you madam chair
it's obvious that we didn't have a lot
of time to put this together and I and I
suppose the amendment reveals that I I
don't have a lack of confidence in d e s
to get this rulemaking done there's no
way that they would drag it out year
after year that just doesn't behoove
anyone's interest I wish the wording
could be amended
that would preclude that drawing out for
Infinity but again these we're talking
about professionals I I just don't see
that as a realistic option that it would
happen
I don't know if we can on the Fly add
that abeyance is important to all of us
every one of us
so if our Amendment could be amended to
put abeyance in that section
I would love to do that
I believe it's a little late because we
would we are voting on this amendment
today now
representative germano thank you madam
chair I had an idea and I thought better
of it and I thought better of thinking
better of it uh so so thank you
um I one of the issues that I've
repeatedly raised is a concern about the
extension of the abeyance and whether it
could be made a shall uh Clause as
opposed to a May clause and how that
might work and I talked to OLS about
that so that has been a concern of mine
from our discussions however I I've
become increasingly
to think that I'm not also not concerned
that this is not going to be completed
in the 24-month period in part because I
think one of the things that that was
made clear throughout all of her
testimony is we're not talking about new
science here right we actually already
have the science uh that we need in
order to to to make the current rules we
could do a survey of states around us
and look at a variety of options Des
could present those to this committee
into the legislature and then the
legislature could could drive that
process so I don't actually think that
there's any danger that this is not
going to be completed in a 24-month
period so uh while I I think the point
is is a really good one I think it is
left vague and would prefer it not to be
I don't see a danger in it extending
beyond the 24 month period thank you
madam chair
thank you
okay
um any other comments or questions on
this particular Amendment
so I will reiterate what uh what I've
heard here from the um house Clerk
that um we would have to merge these
amendments to have only one Amendment
from the committee
if they don't work together it's going
to be an issue so seeing as we've passed
the previous Bixby Amendment
um
passing this amendment to will cause
many problems I don't know how that
would be rectified
because there is different language in
both of these amendments
and for that reason I can't support this
amendment
if there are any other questions or
comments about this
um
I would say that the clerk should call
the roll
thank you madam chair we're voting to
adopt Amendment
2023-1980h Madam chair no
represent bogert
no representative comtwa yes
representative verbal yes representative
Davis
resume call come
no
represent coulon
represent Kenny
representative Potenza yes
representative smart
represent Bixby no representative
sophocitus
representative dutzie
represent Murray
representative yes
representative Haskins yes
representative Howard no
representative NAB no
representative Horrigan no
represent Voigt yes
motion fails the vote is 10 to 10.
thank you now do I hear emotion
ought to pass through the amendment
representative Bixby
I've moved ought to pass with Amendment
uh 1979 each
any questions or comments I I second
that I'm sorry I second that motion uh
represent Bixby would you like to speak
to your motion uh I think we've covered
the ground fairly thoroughly so I think
we should just move to the vote okay
uh with that uh representative germana
thank you madam chair and I want to say
first of all that I appreciate all the
the hard work and I respect the
Integrity of uh of my committee
colleagues who work so hard to make this
bill something we can live with I want
the public who are here or the public
who are watching uh streaming online I
want to
I want to let them know that everybody
on this committee is
working with the best interests I
genuinely believe everyone on this
committee is working with the best
interests of the people of the State of
New Hampshire in mind this is uh a
sausage making process and uh and and it
can be really difficult at times but but
I have enjoyed working with all of you
and as I said I don't doubt for a moment
your commitment anyone on this committee
to uh to the people of this state
the the more I told myself
that some bill was better than no bill
the more ultimately I came to realize
that I was just trying to justify voting
for a bill that in the end I can't
support when we look at a couple of of
examples of language that we couldn't
get into the bill
to me this is just stunning we couldn't
get ample margin of safety into the bill
because of political pressure and
pressure from a lobbyist we couldn't get
variability across a site if we can't
have testing that gives us variability
across the site
you could test within I don't know a 50
square foot section you could put 10 10
test drills in a 50 square foot section
that's not a site-specific test that's a
50 square foot specific test that gives
the desired result
in the end as I said I do genuinely
believe that we can't let the enemy or
the perfect be the enemy of the good
this bill crossed a line at a certain
point where I no longer felt we were
actually doing the good so again I want
to appreciate
the work of all of my colleagues and
express my admiration for all of the
work that this committee has done and
how well Madam chair you have conducted
these these hearings but in the end I
cannot vote for the bill thank you
representative Howard
thank you madam chair
um while I agree 100 with representative
germanna except for voting against this
bill we are buying ourselves time with
this we and I believe that it's
important time I think it's a it's a
good um a good uh purchase of of time
and I would hope that people would
support it so that we can do something
better in the next two years
representative Haskins I too have used
the metaphor about the perfect and the
good
but I don't think it is good as it
stands which is why I can't vote for it
and I also don't think that the
Amendments necessarily conflict
uh you know I don't know enough about
the process but I I don't think that
they are conflicting amendments so that
um comment from the clerk
um does an outline expressly what can be
done about that
thank you
representative erval
thank you madam chair so I agree with
the
two of the three previous speakers
um for not the reasons they outlined uh
but I I agree that that this bill
um even as amended is is not a good bill
it is it is not the solution that any of
us are looking for it has flaws on on
both both sides of the perspective
um and for that reason I too am not
going to vote in favor of Passage thank
you madam chair
thank you
any other any other comments questions
okay I will direct a clerk then to call
the roll thank you madam chair we're
voting on SB 61 as amended by
2023-1979h Madam chair yes
represent bogert yes Representative no
Representative verville no
representative Davis
represent colcom
yes
represent coulon
represent Kenny
represent Potenza no represents smart
represent Bixby
representative
representative dutzie
represent Murray Representative germana
no representative Haskins no
representative Howard
representative NAB yes representative
Horrigan yes Representative no
one two three four
motion passes 12 to 8.
thank you everybody on this committee I
wanna uh I appreciate all the work
the discussion
um I feel your frustrations
um
but in the end I think uh us putting
something
that we can bring back to the Senate
will be something that will be workable
and
um
I would also like to uh
extend my apologies
to Mr demiers
publicly because I believe it's
inappropriate to attack anybody
personally from this body
and there were some words that were said
earlier which I was disappointed to hear
so please accept at least my apology for
um for those words
and
representative Bixby so I'd also like to
thank the committee for working
diligently on this bill I
have been
um
frustrated that we have not been able to
get the bill we would have liked to pass
both bodies I think that HB 56 was a
much better Bill than what we have just
passed
but uh I think that it is really
important to have the time without
having to worry about a permit going in
with the next two years to get better
rules than what we have now and I also
appreciate uh the disc when we discussed
uh this a couple weeks ago we talked
about the possibility of having a
subcommittee from this committee that
would be working on oversight of the
entire process and I hope that we carry
through on that and I hope that we get
members from both sides of this vote uh
as well as both sides of this aisle to
uh of the aisle to participate in that
oversight committee
thank you thank you um
so I think we will set up a subcommittee
depending on what happens with this bill
as it goes forward
um also I imagine uh representative
Bixby that you will be writing the
majority report for this
I will be writing the majority report
um I think that those who are in
opposition to the bill should decide who
they want as to write The Minority
Report because I think it might come out
uh I I think that the votes against were
not always all for the same reason so I
think that those who are in the minority
should uh decide among themselves who
should write that Minority Report okay
representative verbal thank you madam
chair yeah I noticed the Minority Report
coming down I have no problem yielding
to others if they prefer to write that
Minority Report that is obviously going
to be a floor fight on this bill and I'd
be more than artistic more than happy to
articulate my opposition uh during the
floor debate if if somebody else prefers
to write The Minority Report
representative Haskins
as co-sponsor of the bill I'd be happy
to write the report okay
representative Murray uh thank you this
is a question for you madam chair is
there a majority and a minority report
for each potential Amendment or because
the amendment
okay Bill as a whole okay thank you
and so I would like to have that
Minority Report this afternoon if
possible
or this evening you can email it to me
same with you representative Bixby
okay thank you
representative Horrigan well I'm I'm
just a substitute so I missed a lot at
the beginning but it I sounded like
what represented Potenza and Haskins
what they had in mind was sort of a
superset of what representative Bixby
gave us so they
approved of everything that was in the
Bixby Amendment but they may have worded
some of it differently I guess and then
they had more before is that is that my
correct understanding of what happened
to her it was slightly different yes
okay
any other questions or comments so we
will be having um uh I'm going to end
the exact session for SB 61 first of all
thank you everyone for all your work and
discussion
um working together and um agreeing to
disagree on some things thank you now we
will have a presentation by Des this aft
this right now we were supposed to start
it at 10 30 and I I had let them know we
may be running a little late but uh
please welcome and um
thank you
our
our substitutes are welcome to stay and
listen to the presentation
but it's not otherwise you're free to go
um probably a half hour 45 minutes
yeah I
think we'll be done by now
yes exactly
our pleasure thank you yes volunteers
substitute
it is you can do
you know
it would be interesting writing the
group of people who voted on both sides
of that issue it's just a weird
illumination you'll never see those
exact alignments
are we breaking for five minutes
and as soon as they get set up here yeah
so so when everybody's back in we'll
we'll get started I'm sorry to keep you
oh yeah no worries we'll give it a few
minutes thanks
[Music]
so everything for verbal
okay thank you very much
and I think we can give that to Gene I
mean
all right uh
one second while representative Davis
comes back from delivering that paper
and we'll get started
okay
welcome
thank you madam chair thank you for the
committee for uh inviting us here to
give an update on soil pfas in New
Hampshire and an update on biosolids my
name is Jeff Martz I'm the administrator
of the Hazardous Waste remediation
Bureau at DES I'm also a hydrogeologist
and our Bureau is tasked with developing
soil remediation standards for pfas and
I'm going to give the update on soil and
then Anthony Drew in here we'll talk
more about biosolids
so I want to cover four topics in a
relatively short period of time give you
a high level overview the first is the
USGS soil study task number one which
was to evaluate soil pfas and in Shallow
soil across the state then I'm going to
give an example of pfas and soil at a
contaminated site
next they're going to talk about the
USGS task 2 laboratory leaching
experiments I'm only going to briefly
touch on that and then I'm going to get
into the New Hampshire Des pfas oil
remediation standard development give
you a brief update on where we are
so back in 2019 uh when new lower
stringent standards were adopted for
pfas in groundwater became apparent that
we're going to have to adopt eventually
standards that were protective of
groundwater but there was a lot of
emerging science on the complexity of
how pfas behave in the in the
environment and we thought it was
important to identify one what type of
pfas are present in New Hampshire soils
and to identify some of the factors
specific to New Hampshire soils that
affect leachability of these compounds
so Des partnered with U.S Geological
Survey to do a three-part study that
included one the characterization of
shallow soil pfas which I'll talk about
on some more slides task two was to
assess the partitioning or or the
passage of pfas from soil to liquid in
the environment and what are the
important factors that influence that in
our state soils I'm not going to go into
this in a lot of detail it's a very
complex topic but I'm going to talk
about how that's going to inform our
soil remediation standard development
finally the task 3 evaluated pfas
transport at two sites one where there
was an a triple F release site and the
other was a biosolid site and
unfortunately I don't have time to get
into that the results of that study
so here's a slide that was put together
by Andrea takranov the lead investigator
from the USGS as well as her team
including Leah santangelo and Sydney
Welch as well as some Des staff Kate I'm
a slow Sher myself and Anthony drouin
and I'm going to show several slides
that were put together by USGS and they
had the USGS logo in the bottom
so the the steady design for the soil
sampling across the state the purpose of
that was to characterize pfas and
shallow soil in areas throughout New
Hampshire that are not known to be
impacted by a contaminated or a local
pfas source so to do this the USGS
gritted the state into a hundred equal
area cells and then classified lands as
either a forested shrubland or
herbaceous to kind of filter out Urban
lands and then they placed a 500 meter
buffer around Parcels where we had
potential pfas contamination or releases
and next they use GIS to randomly
generate sites for sampling in each one
of those hundred sites was sampled the
soil was sampled from zero to six inches
and then at 50 of those sites they
collected a sample from 6 to 12 inches
and at a smaller subset they collected
some deeper soil samples to characterize
pfas across the state
so I'm going to jump right into some of
the results uh from this study and on
the left hand side showing the
concentration that was detected in the
shallow soil samples for pfoa one of the
compounds that we regulate in
groundwater and the units presented are
in nanograms per gram which is
equivalent to a part per billion in soil
and it supported to differentiate that
from parts per trillion that we regulate
in groundwater so different orders of
magnitude but the scale goes from uh
below detection at 0.5 to greater than
three parts per billion for pfoa and one
of the takeaways when you look at this
graph is that the colors get warmer
meaning there's generally a increase in
concentration As you move from the
northern part of the state to the
southern part of the state
next moving to the middle plot is the
concentration of pfos and what we see is
a more random distribution of some of
the higher concentrations compared to
the lower concentrations and we're
currently investigating why that might
be but it could be a function of how
pfos behaves tends to be a little
stickier to soil compared to pfoa
and finally the the plot on the right is
a measure called the top assay which is
used to measure the presence of
precursors so I think you probably heard
that there are thousands of pfas
chemicals but we only regulate four so
this top assay was to get at whether
there are precursors in the soil and the
good news the takeaway is that there
seem to be very little precursors
present in New Hampshire soils
foreign
plot showing the concentrations detected
for each of the pfas compounds so the
pfas compounds are listed across the
bottom it's a bar and whisker plot with
concentration of pfas and soil
increasing towards the top of the plot
and what I'd like you to take away is
that this blinking blue line is at the
concentration of one part per billion
and that one part per billion is the
common laboratory detection limit for
most commercial Laboratories so one of
the key takeaways from the study is that
most of the soil samples for most of the
compounds were below that detection
limit by most common Laboratories so
they wouldn't have been detected if we
sent them to any laboratory so the USGS
worked with the laboratory that Des was
using to develop a lower detection limit
to an in order to characterize these
soils
also want to call your attention to the
black bold line in the center of the
boxes that value represents the median
or an average of the samples for each
compound and if you look at pfoa which
is towards the left hand side of the
plot you can see that the median for
pfoa is just below that one part per
billion minimum detection level for
common Laboratories and similarly pfos
which is on the right hand side that
median value is very close to that one
part per billion level
so next I'm going to talk briefly about
an example of a contaminated site Saint
Cobain in Southern New Hampshire where
they had air emissions the image on the
right is a depiction and a color
representation of the modeled air
deposition of the compound pfoa with the
warmer colors the yellows representing a
higher concentration of pfoa that was
deposited on the ground and the cooler
colors representing lower concentrations
but not insignificant with respect to
groundwater and what we see when we zoom
in on the site the image on the left is
an excerpt from one of the site
investigation reports showing pfoa in
soil and what you can see from the
orange colored samples is that some of
the samples on this figure exceeded 200
parts per billion which is our direct
contact value for soil so we had very
high concentration so most of the data
from the USGS sampling effort was below
apart per billion and adjacent to single
main we had in the excess of 200 parts
per billion just to give you a sense of
the range and if you look at a triple F
release sites we also see hundreds of
parts per billion where a triple F was
applied to the ground
foreign
this to the to the groundwater it's very
complex and a kind of like a an onion uh
that there are many layers that
influence ultimately the concentrations
that we see in groundwater so the amount
of air deposition that occurs the
surfacial geology coupled with the
Bedrock geology as well as time related
factors such as changes in the chemicals
released over time seasonal variations
all influence what we see when we sample
groundwater and the image on the lower
right represents pfoa measured in water
supply Wells inside the cincobain
consent decree area and we see a very
complex pattern where the green dots
represent less than half of our ambient
groundwater quality standard of 12 so
that's zero to six parts per trillion
and they can be immediately adjacent to
water supply Wells that exceed our
standard of 12 parts per trillion so we
see this very complex pattern and I
attribute to that to the many
complexities of how these compounds move
through the environment
Switching gears now I'm going to talk a
little bit about SRS the soil
remediation standard development so we
have a director from the legislature to
initiate rulemaking for the four
compounds that we regulate in
groundwater that rule making must be
initiated by November 1st now we do have
the direct contact risk-based values
which I said some of the soil sink
domain exceeds 200 for pfoa so our S1
direct contact risk-based values to be
protective of a child playing in the
soil and maybe incidental ingestion and
it's 200 for pfoa and 100 for the other
three compounds that we regulate
this is a chart we'll provide some PDF
so you can look at this later but this
is a chart put together by the itrc
summarizing national values and as you
can just a brief takeaway is that
they're substantially lower than our
direct contact values
there are five factors that we consider
when we're developing a soil remediation
standard include those direct contact
risk-based soil concentrations that I
mentioned and then they involve leaching
based soil concentration so this is
where that task 2 from the USGS study
comes into play where they looked at
various factors that influence
leachability such as pH total organic
carbon content and even things such as
protein so we Factor all this in as we
evaluate leachability of these compounds
third we have to take into account
background concentrations so that's
where task one of the USGS study where
the 100 samples come into play to uh
help inform our understanding of
background and what concentrations are
occurring in soils across the state
uh fourth we're going to take into
account ceiling concentrations and these
generally tend to apply to other
compounds that have odor thresholds so I
don't expect that to play a big role but
it's something we're considering and
finally a practical quantification
limits so this this speaks to the
laboratory's ability to detect these
compounds and like I mentioned earlier
on that bar and whisker plot
conventional Laboratories at the time we
did this study were detecting down to
about one part per billion but there are
some new EPA methods coming along that
are expected to have a lower practical
quantification limit so we'll be able to
measure these compounds at lower
concentrations
so lastly I just want to close uh by
tying this into groundwater the map on
the right shows Wells that contain less
than half of our standard of 12 parts
per trillion for pfoa so the green shows
zero to six parts per trillion in
groundwater samples so even though we
are seeing a widespread occurrence of
pfasts and soils across the state that
doesn't necessarily equate to widespread
exceedance of our current standards for
pfoa and our other other compounds so
with that I can either turn it over to
Anthony or take take questions
I have a question
how
how does New Hampshire compare to other
states with regard to the concentrations
that you're measuring
uh that that's a great question if we
had more time I could show a slide
comparing us to Vermont Vermont did a
study back in like 2018 and our our
value our for pfoa was probably a little
higher on average than than Vermont but
generally they track somewhat similarly
representative Murray ah thank you madam
chair um thank you for taking my
question one of the things that I do
want to ask is uh we're well aware that
New Hampshire has the 12 parts per
trillion standard uh that was enacted
into law but as far as
um the current U.S EPA is looking at
National drinking water standards that
may expand into looking at uh six pfas
sort of chains
um and I was curious to know
are you seeing any parity I understand
the chemicals react differently in soils
than they do water but are you seeing
any effort or desire from your
department to
um
perhaps follow what's happening with the
national drinking water standards
obviously and then adjust soil and or
water based on what comes out of that
um great great question so so by law if
those Federal mcls are adopted so those
are drinking water standards they would
be adopted most likely as a drinking
water standards in the state and then by
law our ambient groundwater quality
standard would become equivalent to
those those Federal MCL so the new
ambient groundwater quality standard
would become four if they were adopted
as proposed for pfoa and pfos
any other questions no thank you very
much for that thank you
and will we be able to get
um emailed a copy of the slides yeah
we'll email uh PDFs of the thank you
slides I know there's a lot a lot in
there yeah thanks
also good morning everyone and I want to
thank Madam chair uh for inviting me
today to speak to you guys my name is
Anthony drone I'm the supervisor of the
residuals management section at New
Hampshire Das we are the section within
the Wastewater engineering Bureau that
does regulate biosol land application uh
the hauling of sludge the management of
biosols or sludge post wastewater
treatment facility and also the
management of septic in the state
so today what I'm going to do is talk a
little bit about biosolid regulations to
Clean Water Act why we're here what is
sludge management how did it become what
it is today uh just a little bit of what
our education Outreach efforts have been
uh since 2018 2019 when pfas really hit
the news for Wastewater uh going to talk
about how is sludge septage and leachate
managed in the state going to give you
some numbers some annual numbers to look
at to think about how much volume do we
create and then the investigation that
we've been doing since 2017 uh just as a
note I joined DES in August of 2018 I
immediately took over the pfas
investigation and all the work related
to pfas and biosolids and then that
investigation ramped up to Beyond
biosolids and we looked into collection
systems which you'll see that data today
and then lastly I wanted to talk about
the future of sludge management New
Hampshire the technologies that we are
looking at for destruction of sludge and
maybe some assistance we could have and
looking further into those Technologies
so first I always do a quick Shameless
plug of who we are right now we are down
one person uh it's pretty common at DES
at this time unfortunately but as you
can see I'm the supervisor I have
oversight of the sludge quality
certification program which I'll go over
that is the permit to distribute
biosolids in the state of New Hampshire
we do have a permitting enforcement
engineer she just left our section
recently to go to a different section at
DES so we are looking for a new engineer
for that position unfortunately we don't
have any applicants yet but that'll
hopefully change soon Wade Pelham is our
sludge and septage coordinator he does
all our education Outreach he runs our
Wastewater man Water and Wastewater
manager school where we take operators
and get them to be trained to be
managers the future superintendents of
New Hampshire
and then Jim talvey is our inspector he
inspects all our hauling land
application and uh facilities like our
lagoons that we have oversight of with
the permit system
so just real quick you know prior to the
Clean Water Act our Rivers were quite
contaminated if you're old enough to
understand what the Cuyahoga River is
that thing was on fire in Ohio uh this
incident really created the need for the
EPA before this the EPA wasn't around
and the Clean Water Act soon began
discussion of the Clean Water Act about
this and this is really how EPA came to
be what they are today but as you can
see the Cuyahoga River was full of
pollution so it wasn't the bay uh New
York near Ellis Island
we also had local Rivers uh Merrimack
was the Merrimack River was deemed one
of the most polluted rivers in new uh
the country back before the Clean Water
Act you can see here a couple main
rivers where there's some paper mills
discharging directly into the surface
water prior before any treatment was
ever put onto the system
but what did the Clean Water Act do it
began to clean up our surface water
bodies and did a great job doing that
we're now able to recreate on these
surface water bodies and we even have
now drinking water supplies that exist
on these Rivers themselves and you can
see here president uh former President
Reagan back in 1984 in the State of the
Union Address made a very valid point
preservation of our environment is not a
liberal or conservative challenge it is
common sense this is not a political
situation is really about us and the
people that we live with
so the rules and laws that we work with
for residuals management and Wastewater
Management in the state we have our
Clean Water Act which was passed in 1972
RSA 485 which is the water pollution and
waste disposal act which I'm sure you
all are aware of that was passed in 1990
for federal regulations under the Clean
Water Act section 405-d it specifically
states that the department EPA is to
develop rules and regulations on the
management of sludge those are your 40
CFR part 503 rules you'll often hear
them called the 503 regulations
for New Hampshire we have two rule sets
for the management of sludge and septic
envwq 800 is our sludge management rules
and emvwq 1600 is our septage management
rules we do have two different
Management Systems there because septage
is not when you're managing septids
prior to a wastewater treatment facility
it definitely needs to have its own
oversight and different regulations but
they are similar uh and if you look at
it from a higher level
so some of the efforts that we have uh
done this year we have our or in the
last few years our sludge quality
certification investigation for pfas has
been going on since 2017. again I joined
DES in 2018 uh back in 2019 is when I
revised everybody's such quality
certificate to state that you are to
monitor for pfas annually at that time
we were only looking at nine compounds
because that's all the labs could
analyze for today I can get a list of 24
up to 40 and even up to 70. your method
from the EPA the multi-lab validated
method that will be for soils and sludge
will be a list of 40 compounds
we also created the Northeast biosolid
Improvement program that is a national
group now we have multiple State
Regulators Engineers operators Managers
from all sides of the industry coming
together to create education Outreach
what you're looking at here is part of
one of our brochures we created for the
public to talk about how pfas is
conveyed through the Wastewater system
and not a source in a Wastewater plan is
not the source of pfas in fact it's the
victim of pfas from industry and
residence
this is another part of the brochure
that we created to educate our operators
and septic haulers in the state to
understand why is the septage or why are
why is there more sampling happening at
the Wastewater Plant and the difference
between the sampling that they've done
in the past and the sampling that
they'll do in the future because this
now involves clean water sampling
protocols where they have to pay
attention to what they're wearing if any
of you are wearing makeup lotion or any
other health and beauty care products
today you might be contributing pfas to
the Wastewater system when you wash it
off your face at night
and that's what they have to be careful
of when they're sampling for because
they can cross contaminate the sample
with that material that might be on
their body on their hands on their
clothes that then can transfer back into
the sample
we've also again educated the public on
what is pfas and how does it impact
Wastewater systems and sludge Management
systems and then what they can do to POS
possibly reduce those concentrations
there's a website called
pfastcentral.org it has an awesome
Banner at the top it educates you on
what you can buy that doesn't contain
pfas meaning you're cleaning chemicals
your clothes and things like that so you
can make the effort personally at home
to try to reduce those loadings I'm
going to show you some data here that'll
show you how residents are discharging
pfas into the Wastewater system and it
might be actually of a concern since a
residents are the mass loading onto a
Wastewater Plant
we've also done some articles with NPR
and other media Outlets if you remember
last fall if you saw last fall I was the
subject of marhopal Mason's article on
what we're doing for pfas regulation
standard development what Jeff just
explained to you uh this was a great
article I worked with Mara all year long
on this uh took the A out to our sample
sites also took they out to our farm
field where we did the phase three part
of the study at one of our biosolid
sites
so I want to give you some quick numbers
on sludge and septage management in the
state we recycle approximately over 40
000 wet tons of biosolids from the
wastewater treatment facilities in New
Hampshire there's quite a few towns that
are reliant on this permit program uh if
you're representing a town or community
and your interest is to know if you are
recycling come ask me and I'll let you
know but there are quite a few
we landfill about 50 000 wet tons of
biosolers or sludge annually we call
that sludge because it's not treated so
we're cycling about 35 percent of the
sludge that's generated in the state
we're making we're managing or creating
about a hundred over a little over a
hundred thousand wet tons annually on a
250 Day schedule that's almost 13
tractor trailer trucks per day
um of sludge that needs to be managed
whether it's a landfill incinerated or
land applied
we're also managing over 100 million
gallons of septage annually that's being
hauled around by our septic haulers and
brought to a Wastewater Plant or a
permanent facility if you don't know 80
about 85 percent of the state is on
septic systems so this is a very
important Management program and a very
important program to keep an eye on to
make sure that all the SEPTA is just
properly being disposed at the right
place
as for our six operating line landfills
in the state we are generating over 100
million gallons of leachate annually
that is mostly being managed in the
state at our local wastewater treatment
facilities if you're unaware leachate
that's generated at a landfill has to go
to a wastewater treatment facility to be
further processed and then discharged to
the surface water body or groundwater if
that Wastewater Plant has a rapid
infiltration Basin which is discharges
into the ground so quite a bit of
leachate has to be managed in the state
still if you remember a few years ago
there was an article about the Lowell
Wastewater facility taking New Hampshire
leachate after that article they quickly
stopped taking that leachate and now
that leachate is going to New Jersey to
be treated so they're shipping their
leachate about eight hours down the road
to be treated at a Wastewater Plant
what I'm going to show you here is the
beginning of our investigation I start
with the collection system meaning we go
out and Sample the sewer shed out in the
streets we pop manholes we go into pump
stations and we do different sampling
methods to see what we can find in the
Wastewater and we're looking for General
sources of pfas entering the Wastewater
stream via industry or the public when
we do this we aren't pinpointing
specific businesses we are actually
looking at general areas so if there's a
parking lot that has a bunch of box
stores we're sampling that pump station
so it's not specifically one business
there may be and here you may see a
school here or there there was a pump
station that we did sample for a high
school and there were a couple of other
entities beyond that what you're seeing
here right now is a community this is
Sunapee New Hampshire they have the more
higher concentration of pfas in their
sludge which had me wondering why it's
mostly a residential Community with not
much industry so we went around and
sampled the residential communities of
this system and what this is is tapas so
it's total oxidizable precursor assay
and what they're doing is they're
measuring the pfas in the sample and
then they're oxidizing the sample and
then re-measuring it again by oxidizing
the sample what they're doing is
breaking up all those precursors Jeff's
just talked about the ones that we can't
see in the normal test method and
exposing them and then we're able to see
what is really the concentration of per
se pfos and pfoa
so you'll see on this chart pre and post
and the letter before that is means it's
the same sample so when we sample the
normal test method that is used today we
don't see it and we go okay it's not
coming from residence but then if we do
top assay all of a sudden it exposes the
amount of precursors that a home is
discharging meaning it could be coming
off your makeup your lotions your soaps
your laundry detergent your clothes we
just don't know because the sds's that
are out there for products that are sold
to us don't indicate if pfas is in it
because it's at such a small
concentration they don't legally have to
do that and if they do then they usually
typically say it's proprietary or trade
secrets so we don't even know what
products we're buying off the shelf
contain pfas and what those
concentrations are but as you can see
here uh there is a contribution from
residents and it goes all the way up to
600 parts per trillion this is not parts
per billion this is parts per trillion I
will show you sludge data in a sec that
is parts per billion just like Soil and
Water you will find soil sludge and
parts per billion you'll find water in
parts per trillion so this was
concerning to me this actually started
to say there's actually a different
picture being painted where it's not
just industry just charging pfas into
our collection systems is also us
this right here is a different Community
this is North Conway we've gone out and
done various other communities and we're
going to continue doing this with the
the money that we're getting from
legislation to continue our
investigation this is North Conway so
you can see here this resident loading
is very similar to uh Sunapee if you
look at the scale below the scale is
obviously much higher because I actually
went and sampled some industry and
Commercial areas of this community
this next sample was actually very
alarming to me because this is the high
school Pump Station
this means that the high school is
discharging quite a bit of pfas into the
collection system that is zorbing onto
the sludge hence contaminating the
sludge in the Wastewater
we're finding through other
investigations that this is coming out
of the cleaning chemicals the floor
strippers and floor waxes that they're
using at these schools and also is
coming off of the surfaces that the
school has through the studies that are
drinking water groundwater Bureau has
done with these uh constituents so this
is alarming uh because we do have a lot
of schools in the state that have
drinking water wells and septic systems
and they are now on granulated activated
carbon for those Drinking Water Systems
curiosity I have for Wastewater is is a
septic system doing this or not we don't
know we need more data
um do you want to wait till after okay
thank you
yeah please
what you're looking at here is leachate
uh this community actually has a
circular system with their sludge and
their leachate they have a landfill and
then they generate sludge from their
their Wastewater Plant the sludge is
land filled and the leachate goes back
to the Wastewater Plant there's not many
of these types of systems in New
Hampshire because uh our sludge and our
leachate and our go in multiple
different directions on different days
but this system is pretty pretty unique
so what you're seeing here is that
there's not much of difference between
the pre and the post so the leachate is
probably oxidizing through the landfill
exposing all those precursors to what
they are but there is a loading of uh
leachate on here we now have some
research going on where this community
is actually going to look at how could
they potentially treat the leachate
before it hits the headworks of the
Wastewater Plant hopefully reducing this
loading at least from the leachate
this is what we see in the influent and
effluent of the Wastewater Plant so if
you were to do the standard analysis
today you wouldn't see it in the
influent but if you do it on the
effluent you would see it so that
initially brought the conversation of a
Wastewater Plant is generating pfas it
is not it is conveying it through the
system because a Wastewater Plant is not
designed to treat emerging contaminants
it's designed to treat the solids and
the pathogens that are present in the
Wastewater separating out the two
discharging clean water to the surface
water body and creating sludge so this
top assay really exposes how there is a
lot of unknown pfas entering into the
Wastewater Plant through systems like
the school or residents or even
businesses as you can see on this chart
there are other larger ones the
commercial LR that is your Home Depot
and Walmart location and then your LS
gsmh that other higher number that is a
hotel and Retail center of North Conway
so as residents and just retail so no
industry or any type of Agriculture or
anything like that
next I want to show you the sludge data
that we've generated so this is just
last year's data I have data which I'll
show you in a sec that goes all the way
back to 2017. as you can see on the
bottom this is in parts per billion so
the highest concentration we find in
class A biosolids right now is a little
over six parts per billion for pfos it's
a little over four parts per billion and
for pfna and pfhxs it does not meet or
meets one part per billion as you see
there's different generators here some
of this biosolids is strictly for Farm
fields and some is allowed to be land
applied on your golf course on your
ballpark and potentially on your lawn if
you choose to work with that Company
Merrimack is on here Hawk Ridge is on
here those are both in vessel compost
systems which I'm looking at because
that energy that that composting does I
think breaks up a lot of these
precursors into those known pfas
compounds we see
but again
the maximum concentration we saw in
phase one was about eight parts per
billion for pfos so this is six parts
per billion just to take note
for the class B biosolids we have three
generators and in fact the green line
that is our New Hampshire Des run
Wastewater facility the Winnipesaukee
River Basin program they service 10
communities in the state and their
biosolids was typically land applied at
class B permanent sites but recently has
now being trucked down to Merrimack to
their Compost Facility because their
contract changed and the company that
was managing it doesn't manage it
anymore to those Farm Fields so while I
have this in the class B numbers I want
to show you because the Winnipesaukee
River Basin program treatment is very
much similar to the Nashua treatment
Nashua is the largest generator of
biosolids in the state they generate
about 9 000 wet tons annually due to the
population
and down below is Plymouth they're a
smaller Community they lime stabilize
their biosolids so they use Quick lime
to kill the pathogens which is a higher
pH material which has to be paid
attention in the field so you're not
raising the pH too high
uh this is short paper fiber coming from
our paper mills so keep in mind that
scale the heart largest concentration we
see does not exceed 1.8 parts per
billion our paper mills today probably
aren't using pfas like they used to or
maybe just aren't using at all as you
heard maybe in the news the main Farms
that were contaminated might have been
contaminated from paper sludge I think
when you look at paper sludge you have
to look at what is the paper mill making
and how much pfas could possibly be a
potential in that process the monado
paper mill this is the first time they
ever had a hit period with me this one
year their procurement program they're
actually asking their vendors are you
testing for pfas what are your numbers
can I see those and they're making a
decision on what they're taking in for
recycled feedstock based on those
constant conversations they took that
from my training I gave them I wanted
the plants to start that are taking in
outside waste to start understanding
what's coming into the plant and start
having those conversations and
potentially testing for it stupid
what you're seeing here is drinking
water residuals we do allow drinking
water sludge to be land applied it has
to be blended with soil to make a
manufactured topsoil we don't allow it
to be directly land applied onto Farm
Fields but again keep in mind that scale
highest concentration goes to 1.8 part A
little over 1.8 part per billion
so quickly I want to talk about the
future of sludge management
um
we are looking at destruction Pathways
and what is feasible and what could be
done with our sludge in the future to
better manage this material paralysis
and gasification are two technologies
that seem to be pretty applicable to
sludge sludge is a pretty complex Matrix
you just can't add on any technology to
it and have successful destruction but I
am seeing that paralysis is creating a
biochar that is completely free of pfas
and in fact biochar has a value to the
market in California they're selling
biochar for about 300 a yard so a
Wastewater Plant could potentially be
generating a material that's safe for
the environment and had creating a
revenue source for themselves if they
have this technology there are concerns
about the air emissions of these
Technologies so that's what we need to
look at if they were to burn and Destroy
This would they be emitting pfas into
the environment kind of like Saint
Cobain did but you could put scrubbing
on that you could potentially have a
scrubbing system that could treat that
and potentially have that you might see
one of these unit regionally I've heard
grumblings that the Portland Water
District's interested in this and
looking further into this and I've
talked to these companies quite a bit
they are interested in coming into New
Hampshire but they want to make sure
they have a business that's viable
meaning they want to know that they're
if they put one of these units in they
have 20 30 years of business meaning
that our sludge is contaminated enough
that it needs paralysis
this next section this last technology
I'm going to talk about is something
Jeff and I are really interested in uh
we had them present to us last week in
our pfas coordinator meeting it's called
Electro coagulation it almost seems too
good to be true we want to look further
into this one it doesn't have emissions
like burning and incinerating but it
does actually destroy the sludge to a
point where it takes away the pfas or
endocrine disruptors pathogens makes the
metals into oxide forms so that they are
not leachable and actually allow and
destroys the uh it doesn't it takes the
volume of the sludge down 80 percent
because most sludge is actually gas if
you didn't know that and as well it
makes the sludge a better dewatered
material so you can get it drier if you
need to landfill it as you saw with the
numbers that are being recycled 40 000
wet tons would not have a home today if
we were to cut off land application it
would have to be stockpiled or put in a
facility or sent out a state to be
managed right now Canada was taking a
lot of New Hampshire sludge they
recently they just Quebec said no or
they created a moratorium that is
reducing that sludge input and we're
hearing that New Brunswick is about to
quickly follow suit because in Maine
they they did ban land applications
started sending it to the landfill and
within six months the landfill said no
more they sent it to New Brunswick for
about two weeks and then New Brunswick
said we can't do this now they're
talking about railing it down south uh
from from Unity Maine because the
Compost Facility in Unity Maine has now
turned into an emergency stockpile
location that has approval to do that
until August so we want to be careful on
how we manage our sludge in the future
we need to add Outlets to our management
system we right now it's a three-legged
stool land application incineration and
landfilling if you take one of those
legs out you don't have a stool anymore
there's a pun there if you want to think
about it
and we need to add a lake we need to add
a fourth leg and a fifth leg and maybe
even a six leg because this material is
always going to be generated as our
population increases we'll only have
more material to manage and our Farms
are definitely decreasing we are losing
our farms and the management of this
material on our Farms Farmers may not
want this in the future so we need to
start thinking about where does this go
and how do we manage it and how do we
successfully manage it as a state
nope and this is in the dot parking lot
I think this is very appropriate for all
of us
so thank you
um thank you Michelle thank you thanks
for taking my questions so I have a
couple of questions uh the first
question was regarding surfaces at
schools you mentioned uh quote surfaces
can you expand on what you mean by that
so from the study and I don't want to go
too deep into that because it's a
different person I Des that has done
that study Jennifer Hoffman but what she
found is that she would do the analysis
of the chemicals used prior to floor
stripping and waxing and then she would
measure the Wastewater of uh of that
waxing event and also the water used as
part of that so she had essentially
three components when she looked at the
signature of the pfas in the cleaning
chemical and then the signature and the
Wastewater it was different
and it had Legacy signatures to it
suggesting that it was pulling off wax
off the floor the stripping was doing
its job but it was pulling off old wax
that potentially wasn't stripped off
from years past that had a different
chemistry from those chemical companies
as we regulate these chemicals further
you can imagine chemical Engineers are
going to be changing the formulation of
these compounds so they're not so
detectable from test methods but as we
now have tapa and other test messes we
can we can see those changes thank you
and the second question I had was that
um I just briefly went on to your
pfastcentral.org recommendation which is
great I think
um and it's interesting there's a
certain economic subset of of products
available that do not contain some of
these
um the other question I did have around
that was I did notice that there were
virtually no food products there that
disclosed whether or not they were using
hydrophobic Liners in their packaging
that's a very a very good point I mean
we need to definitely look into that I
don't see many investigations happening
about what is what is present in the
food packaging and how is it
transferring into the food and then as
we know there's over or maybe you don't
know but there's over 450 species that
have pfas in their blood and we're
probably one of the most impacted ones
um it's going to be in our blood for the
rest of our lives it might be in your
kids Bloods and your grandchildren's
blood if we don't start changing how we
manage these materials uh so we could we
we're releasing it you know through our
fecal matter and our urine uh every day
and are we eating more of it than we
know I don't know that's that's what the
science needs to show thank you
representative NAB thank you madam chair
thank you for coming in this has been
very fascinating and troubling
um did you figure out what was going on
in Sunapee did you come to any
conclusions about their numbers
um so when I look at Sunapee I to
further investigate we need to have them
do more investigations on different
parts of the collection system
um I think residents are a problem uh
there's a recent article to come out
about toilet paper and actually toilet
paper has a lot of pfas in it and so uh
the article that I've read said that it
could be a problem that was in the
conclusion so with some of this funding
that we're getting in the future here I
am going to be doing a toilet paper
study uh pulling toilet paper off the
shelves of New Hampshire stores and
doing different dilution factors
obviously if you have kids you might be
discharging more toilet paper than if
you don't have kids uh and I want to
kind of see what that looks like and
maybe is that is that a mass loading
that we should be concerned about and
maybe legislation could look into uh how
is this man how is pfas used in Toyota
favorite isn't needed and what it could
be a good substitute for that and then
wipes I don't want to bring up the topic
but wipes could obviously be an issue as
well
yeah so
um I have a lot of questions that I'm
not we weren't we won't be able to cover
all of them uh I think one of the
one of the things that's interesting to
me is the the electrocoagulation because
it sounds like that might be a a really
promising technology and I'm wondering
uh how far away that is from getting up
to scale so I am also very interested in
the longevity and sustainability of that
technology it does use metal plates in
its treatment the metal plates do
deteriorate 0.2 pounds every one
thousand gallons so you can imagine
they're changing out the plates in that
electrolysis bath daily what is the raw
material availability it's an iron and
aluminum plate there's quite a bit of
iron and aluminum in our environment
however if every single Wastewater Plant
started putting this into their lines
what would that demand and Supply look
like as for the technology itself what
we've been told from this one company
they have 150 units worldwide they have
units within the country I am interested
on the safety of the equipment luckily
for New Hampshire and our 700
regulations if you're to implement
anything into a Wastewater Plant that is
new it has to go through a trial to
determine if it is going to be safe for
The Operators is it going to perform the
way it does and then what is that
outcome
thank you madam chair
from an agricultural standpoint with the
use of biosolids and other items
will that leachate into the plants if
there are pfaps or pfoas in that
biosolid so there is literature review
to say that plants do uptake pfas one
thing about agriculture is that
biosolids aren't the only thing being
spread on a farm field that might
contain pfas we haven't looked into
manure yet we haven't looked into
herbicides yet I'm even curious about
osmocote fertilizer which is your coated
nitrogen fertilizer a lot of things that
are used on a farm field that definitely
have not been part of my investigation
because I don't have oversight of that
material if we were to look into
cropping and crop uptake I would we
definitely need Department of AGS
involvement and maybe even usda's
involvement as Maine in their
investigation at their biosolid sites
they did include Department of Ag and
they did include other agencies and
sections of the department to properly
look at these sites so we can't exclude
everything else that is put on a farm
field but there's definitely questions
about what is up being uptaken between
maybe corn silage grain corn hay Rye
soybean and all those other crops
typically our biosolids on an
agricultural setting are only growing
feed for Animals you don't see really
any Farmers using biosolids that are
growing human consumption crops and
that's primarily because if their
customers found out they were using
biosols they probably wouldn't buy their
vegetables so a lot of times they use
animal manure or leaf and laundry
compost but mostly commercial fertilizer
representative come to our well thank
you thank you madam chair so it's my
interesting uh that in order to really
delve into the agricultural side of this
we need you need to we need to partner
with the Department of Agriculture is
that correct that is correct I I you
know if we look at a farm field that is
received biosolids it has not just
received biosolids so you automatically
really have to look into
Department of AG in my section we
regulate the soil the sludge and then we
have as a department we regulate
groundwater our rules and laws do not
regulate crops that is under the
agricultural cultural laws so that would
under be under oversight yeah one last
follow-up thank you so but would your
department is assist in looking at
manure and how that is affecting and
what the Pfaff levels and pfoa levels
are in that absolutely I mean I I'm the
guy that would probably have to train
them on how to do that sampling and I
probably would be the guy that would do
that sampling uh I am pretty much known
as a sludge sampler around the around
the region and Country now uh I have no
fear when it comes to material like that
so I I enjoy training people I did get
an award last year from the EPA on
training due to this compound so I
thoroughly enjoy training others on how
to properly sample for this material
congratulations representative coulon
it seems like if I'm looking at your
Solutions part that
um
it looks like you're considering more
like independent
ways that New Hampshire can
independently deal with waste inside our
own State as opposed to selling it to
other states or other countries an
interesting thing to keep in mind about
sludge is that it doesn't have real
state orders in the management system of
it the interstate commerce law allows
for the material to cross state lines
and be managed in other states I think
as a state though we really need to look
at them how do we look at the management
for our Wastewater plants we have almost
a little over 70 Wastewater plants in
this state that are operating under
Nifty permits that are uh have oversight
from the EPA so if we are able to offer
those Technologies to those Wastewater
plants they may have a safer and more
sustainable future for the management of
that sludge as for an entity that would
manage that destruction and that type of
system private sector seems to be having
all the solutions right now I don't know
if we'd be able to support another
facility next to our state-run
Wastewater plan or anything like that
but the these private companies are
coming in with new technologies and
introducing it to us so they seem to be
working hard on that solution
representative Murray
thank you madam chair thanks again so I
have an interesting question to sort of
think about
um part of the solution obviously you
are saying that as household
it seems that the the evidence suggests
that there's a large portion of pfas
coming out from households to that end I
think a really important component of
this is having the ability for consumers
to know what they're purchasing and
um I am really concerned that maybe that
sort of full picture isn't there for
folks yeah definitely the source
pollution prevention is is the bigger
way we're going to or the easiest and I
think the most efficient way where
you're going to reduce these
concentrations in our collection system
uh as like I said sludge Wastewater and
Wastewater plants are the victim they're
not the suspect and so if we as people
in an industry can discharge less pfas
into that collection system we are now
going to have to manage less at a
municipal system at a public facility
and so if we look at uh controlling the
Commerce of pfas that is definitely a
way to reduce that the labeling of pfas
is definitely a way to get people to
understand what they're buying
um and and as I said on sds's or what
are formerly called msds's pfas is used
at such a small concentration it
technically doesn't have to be on the
SDS so you don't have to disclose that
as part of that chemistry
represent Bixby yeah so um one of
another aspect I'm wondering about is uh
pfas and compost because uh with uh
composting is now not just uh Leaf in a
sort of yard waste but it is also
involves some combination of animal
waste and also food waste and also uh
the sort of
compostable
uh eating uh
containers and uh and and uh
paper dishware which used to just be
landfilled but now could be composted
and also like pizza boxes and that sort
of thing and I'm wondering uh how that
uh so uh have you done any investigation
of compost and how is that panned out so
last fall I was able to go out and buy a
few food waste compost bags at the
general Garden store in New Hampshire it
was down in the south southern part of
the state we looked at
um there were out of state generators
because technically there isn't really a
food waste composter selling bag
products yet in New Hampshire these
rules are pretty fresh
but we did look at that and we did do
sampling and we we saw less
concentrations than what you see in
class A biosolids so it's suggesting
that food waste compost might not be as
impacted as biosolids are and that's
probably pretty true I would say I mean
we definitely need to further that
investigation and look into other
products we looked at four there's
multiple different ones as from the
fertilizer study commission we
understand there's about 800 registered
fertilizers in the state and so how many
of those are being sampled and looked at
I think two what came about that so
um we you know when you look at these
investigations I sample the whole sqc
program I do equipment blanks and field
blanks to Quality check to make sure I
am not cross-contaminating the sample so
I'm looking at everything and I think
you got to do that because wave pfas is
so ubiquitous in our environment you
really have to look it's Case by case
and that could even go with soils
represent Haskins
thank you madam chair just a quick
comment as a member of the advisory
committee of the Seacoast Public Health
Network I get all kinds of information
about pfas a lot of us do
My Town got a grant to test private
Wells
and I think that system is going to be
very helpful
I did notice a press release that um
10 private wells in the towns of Dalton
Whitefield and Bethlehem were also
tested and came out with 0.0 of whatever
combination they were testing so we have
these pristine perennial bodies of water
in our state and we need to protect them
because that's why people want to be
here and move their businesses here so
thanks for the work you're doing thank
you that's our job as Des is to create
standards and regulations that support
the laws and that's what we're doing
today
representative on
thank you madam chair so with the
agricultural like land applications that
have received you know the sludge
dumping for like decades and decades are
you testing the land themselves because
I know there's a lot of sites that have
been receiving this stuff for like a
long time so so we have uh phase three
was looking at an a triple F site and a
biosolid site we sampled the white Farm
facility or white Farm uh on Clinton
Street here that is a state-owned
property so that was pretty easy to get
permission to go out and do that the
investigation has not happened at Farm
fields for a couple reasons a I don't
have the staff manpower to go out and
start sampling every single farm field
that's received biosolids we'd have to
probably develop an RFQ and have a
company go out and do that
also as well we would have to get the
um we could go out and do the class B
sites but the class A sites we'd have to
get permission from the property owner
because those aren't site permitted so
that would involve a lot of work on that
and that we just don't have the Manpower
for so we were able to focus on the
sludge component of our program because
that is the first part how is
distributed and that's where we were uh
doing our sampling so if we do move
forward we would need some money to hire
a company to go out and do that that is
quite a task to take on
foreign
Bixby yeah so um another
um question I have is about how leachate
from landfills is handled and is there
some sort of pre-treatment so that that
doesn't get into so that pfas that might
be in that doesn't get into the
wastewater treatment plant or is the
wastewater treatment plant essentially
getting loaded with what are P whatever
pfas might be in the leachate so uh the
again a Wastewater Plant is not designed
to treat for emerging contaminants so it
is being loaded with pfas whatever's in
that leachate it's being loaded with and
that's you know accumulating in the
sludge or being present in the
Wastewater effluent as it discharges so
when we do look at treatment system
there is uh funding available now to
Wastewater facilities that do accept
leachate to look into treatment systems
that could treat that leachate like I
said North Conway is one of the
applicants for that funding we're very
excited that they're willing to look
into this Jason Gagnon the
superintendent there he's very proactive
on this subject matter and there are a
couple Technologies out there that could
potentially do it we just haven't
completely looked into it
electrocoagulation would be one maybe
supercritical water oxidation could be
another I'm not so sure paralysis and
gasification are the Technologies for
that media because that's a liquid media
and paralysis and gasification is a
solid destructions
I think if you did granule activated
carbon on leachate you'd find that you'd
be going through media pretty quick and
it would clog that media really fast so
the standard granulated activated carbon
that can clean your your private well or
your drinking water plant that's a
cleaner Matrix it can handle that uh as
we know leachate is is the juice from
the landfill so it's not so clean
any other questions no thank you oh
representative I I'm not looking for a
detailed answer now but
um if you have ideas for legislation
that might help you do your job better
or more extensively I think our
committee would be happy to help you out
with uh you know working on that looking
further into destruction is definitely
something we need to do researching it
more seeing what pathway is going to be
a viable outlet for New Hampshire or at
least a safe outlet for our human health
and the environment as our job we are
here to protect human health and the
environment so we want to make sure
whatever technology is coming into the
state it is going to do its job and do
its job safely so that would involve
trials potentially setting allowing
these companies to come in and exhibit
their technology to show are they
properly doing what they're saying
they're doing
guess you need a shark tank huh you know
you're kind of nicer have them come into
New Hampshire and you'd be the Shark
Tank guys right
we can make it a science episode right
okay
well
um we really really appreciate your
presentation this afternoon uh this
morning actually
um and and more so that you were patient
to wait until we were done with uh the
business that we had to attend to as our
committee but um thank you very very
much for taking the time and um and
giving us this very important
information
great thanks Madam chair and and thanks
for the committee for uh giving us the
opportunity to speak today appreciate it
I want to thank you madam chair and the
committee for the opportunity to educate
you on the residuals program not many
people know what happens after you've
flush the toilet so it's good to learn
that thank you
and and you will be sending along your
slides so that we can peruse them a
little bit more
absolutely yeah just just in time for
lunch yeah
thank you very much appreciate it may I
say something uh sure uh represent oh
sure uh representative
yeah this is um I don't need to speak uh
I have I'm on the governor's Council uh
for the main treatment of animals and I
have a survey
I'm on the governor's Council for the
Humane treatment of animals and there's
a survey that we're conducting
um and I was wondering if anyone would
mind if I sent it to you to get your
opinions and please feel free to forward
it on to anybody uh replies are due by
May 31st okay okay thank you send it
along
yeah representative knabb
it's all about
we got an email from
losing their grade yeah what how do we
respond or how do you respond what's the
process of our committee I was going to
forward that along to our uh AG
commissioner to see if there are any
programs that might help them I'm
wondering if they maybe
um something through USDA that they may
be able to get even a small business
loan or something
or FEMA I don't know
um my question to them would be is do
they have crop insurance
yeah
so I I will be responding to uh LaBelle
wineries on on their issue
I think that I don't know I I don't know
which category grapes fall into I know
that there that apples do there is a
USDA problem uh crop protection program
for apples I don't know if there's one
that would cover grapes I suspect
there's probably not one that covers
hearty kiwis yeah
okay
so uh for the committee's information we
still have some retained bills but I
guess we are going to plan to
um discuss those sometime in the fall
and so uh this will be our last meeting
for quite a while and I want to thank
you all I enjoy working with every
single one of you and um I look forward
to uh getting together in the fall
so thank you again
um
and I appreciate it